[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip aujourd'hui
j'ai la joie l'honneur et le plaisir de
recevoir un célèbre yvelinois il est
jardinier en chef du domaine de
versailles
il est auteur de nombreux livres et
imaginez-vous il est aussi correspondant
national de l'académie d'agriculture de
france voilà alain baraton bonjour
journal et je suis très fier de ce
dernier qualificatif l'académie
d'agriculture a été créée par louis 15 à
versailles et l'idée de participer à
cette noble jadis association ne peux
que me réjouir mais je comprends piqué
ménard je ne sais pas c'est un bonheur
je suis élu à vie donc déjà
indéboulonnable c'était pas bon de
désagréable oui mais il faut quand même
se souvenir que c'est l'agriculture qui
nous a dans le passé et qui continue
aujourd'hui de nous alimenter les vider
de poids bien modestement pour ce qui me
concerne mais contribuer aux travaux aux
côtés de grands savants vraiment ne peut
qu'être flatté mais alors du coup en
quoi ça consiste en deux mots bien sûr
l'académie d'agriculture donc les élus
vont réfléchir sur les nouvelles modes
de culture les gestes ou pas a répété
ils ont une réflexion sur la culture en
général française et mondiale en un mot
ce serait je dirais des intellectuels
qui réfléchit sur le devenir du sol de
la manière de le travailler est ce qu'il
faudrait faire pour que l'agriculture
continue à alimenter une population en
constante augmentation
donc c'est quelque chose de très sérieux
selon lui 15 elle fut créée pour lutter
contre les grandes maladies qui décimait
les populations je parle bien sûr des
maladies et donc l'académie
d'agriculture de france a un grand rôle
à jouer dans dans la vie de tous les
jours et vous vous réunissez souvent ils
sonnent j'ai très peu je ne vais pas
mentir mon emploi du temps ne me permet
pas de trop me libérer mais elle se
réunit régulièrement elle a son siège à
paris en bellechasse vacances est une
belle et noble academy que j'apprécie
beaucoup vous écouter vous venez de nous
le prouver alors dites moi aujourd'hui
on est là pour un nouvel ouvrage nous y
voilà on vous souvent vu peau des livres
pour adultes est aujourd'hui que ceux ci
se fassent vous pencher sur les enfants
alors on va parler deux minutes de la
collection ça s'appelle quand ça va
quand ça va pas et elle est créée et
dirigée par maureen dor une fée la
féminine là où j'ai rencontré un jour
une fille qui s'appelle maureen dor
c'est elle qui m'a donné envie d'écrire
cet ouvrage voilà alors le principe de
cette collection chez glénat jeunesse
c'est de prendre un sujet fort un sujet
important donc là en l'occurrence le
jardin il ya eu la république alors et
après on fait parler de ce sujet à
quelqu'un des mérites dans le domaine
est reconnue de ses pairs et ce que dit
marine dans wii u la république comme
vous dites annexes françois hollande va
là ce qui n'est quand même pas rien
d'avoir réussi à convaincre l'ancien
président de la truite de faire non pas
un mais deux ouvrages entre el sayed oui
ensuite elle a également demandé à
michel cymes la médecine et quand elle
m'avait interpellé il ya 4 5 ans déjà
pour savoir si j'accepterais de trail
avec elle je l'aimais d'emory ne voulait
délicieuse est une fée certes mais je ne
peux pas trop me je me disperser et puis
je me suis dit quand même y'a quoi ya
donc deux côtés les revenus me voir j'ai
quand même tu exagères je passe mon
temps à dire qu'il faut apprendre aux
enfants les bons gestes il faut leur
donner l'envié du jardin l'envi de
journée et tu as devant toi une
personnes qui t'encouragent à
transmettre ça vas et tu ne le fait pas
alors il ya un an ou deux j'ai sauté le
pas ce jeudi la marine ok on y va et
c'est le petit lait s'est fait jeter
voilà qui est magnifique et alors moi
qui tu connais de quelques petites
choses mais pas beaucoup j'ai appris
plein de choses je pense que c'est bien
pour les enfants mais aussi pour les
parents en fait pour toutes les
personnes qui sont concernées par la
nature et qui ont envie de s'occuper
d'un jardin même d'avoir un regard un
peu intelligent sur la nature ce qu'il
faut faire ce qu'il faut pas faire et
c'est parce que c'est conçu comme ça
finalement vous prenez plein que tes
sujets oui mais ce que vous venez de
dire le plus beau compliment qu'on
puisse me faire qu'est-ce que de l'aider
que se livrent intéresse autant les
parents que les enfants comment voulez
vous qu'un gamin s'intéresse à un
ouvrage si le papa ou la maman ou les
grands parents eux ne s'y intéressent
pas et j'ai fais une signature ya pas
très longtemps à paris j'ai beaucoup et
était sensible à quantité de deux papys
et mamies qui sont venus acheter le
livre pour leurs petits-enfants mais qui
m'ont dit que avant ils allaient
l'offrir est allé le lire parce qu'il
avait fauté foot et que ça leur plaisait
donc effectivement
ce livre est écrit d'une manière qui
n'est pas stupide ni même ridicule il
s'adresse à des enfants dans un langage
clair mais qui peut aussi intéresser la
grande dame que vous êtes
chic merci et alors sans vouloir être
désagréable
pourquoi pas plutôt vous auriez pu vous
y mettre un peu plus tôt c est ce que
vous êtes grand père maintenant c'est
quatre fois grand père ce sont ces
prénoms la cij
maxime alexis leonardo et matteo
novembre at oui le tout-petit laquelle
allah et c'est vrai que quand je les
vois je vois pas matteau qui est encore
bien petit mais quand je vois alexis et
maxime dans leur jardin du côté de
bordeaux et quand je vois qu'ils adorent
le jardinage quand je vous dis que je
suis peut-être à la tête d'une ligne de
jardy on ne sait jamais mais oui je n'ai
même pas fait de bouquins plomer j'avais
honte et maurice d'or m'a permis de
corriger le mon erreur avec leur maillot
l'illustratrice alors de valve a un
talent exceptionnel
très agréable très joli très explicite
c'est un autre indiquant la clarté je
vous avoue une journalise c'est un
ouvrage collectif parce qu'en fait nous
sommes trois à l'avoir conçu à l'arrière
la dessinatrice kial dessiner d'après
mes propos et moi j'ai travaillé avec
maureen dor qui a vraiment fait la mise
en page c'est elle qui m'a indiqué la
route a suivi l'affairé stries la
structure et donc j'en parle avec
beaucoup de fierté parce que je suis
très fier de cet ouvrage on le lit avec
bonheur avec plaisir et un petit peu de
versets dedans vous avez manqué quelques
dessins mais je suis très très fier et
très heureux de cet ouvrage cette
collaboration oui tout au moins voilà
alors du coup on se rend compte en fait
le leitmotiv un peu de maureen dor c'est
de dire qu'il faut comprendre que la
nature domestiques ou sauvages est aussi
importante qu'une petite fleur entre
deux pavés dans la rue sera aussi
importante qu'un grand chêne au fin fond
du parc oui c'est ça l'idée parce que
tous les enfants n'ont pas de jardin
c'est d'aider tous les enfants n'ont pas
déjà scellé déjà d'encourager les
enfants à défaut de jalla d'aller se
promener dans la nature ou de créer même
dans un petit pot dans un dans une tour
dans un immeuble près de la fenêtre de
la cuisine ça ça peut marcher mais bien
sûr alors ce sera pas x exceptionnel
photo linéaires oui mais il en faut un
minimum et un gamin voulu donner
quelques graines de radis voulu
expliquer qu'une plante est un être
vivant ça nous explique la vie un
végétal ne se développe se multiplient
et meurt c'est un petit peu une très
belle image c'est une leçon de choses
accompagner une leçon de vie donc le but
c'est de permettre aux enfants de
s'intéresser aux plantes de leur
apprendre ce que sont les plantes de
leur dire que dans un jardin il n'y a
pas que des arbres des arbustes mais
aussi des bestioles des insectes quel
est leur rôle lors été dit et il ya des
petits mammifères il ya des oiseaux il
ya de l'eau il ya des bons il ya un
jardinier avec une tenue et avec des
outils c'est tout ça qu'on a voulu faire
une sorte de guide du jardinier et de la
jardinière bien sûr heureux et non plus
grands mon plus grand bonheur c'est vrai
que des petits bouts de chou après avoir
lu cet ouvrage se demandent s'ils
n'étaient pas faits eux aussi pour être
jardinier et j'imagine plus tard les
trains un vieillard à plus rude mais je
m'imagine comme ça aboie mais je suis
déjà très très d'avancé vous et je vous
imagine très bien sur une photo ayant
autant leclaire plaide en recouvrant mes
vieilles jambes et à voir devant moi des
jeunes gens de 25 ans qui me disent
qu'ils sont devenus jardy après avoir lu
mon livre là je serai pour moi la
potennerie ce parce qu'en fait ce que
vous dites c'est que peut-être pas
actuellement j'en sais rien mais avant
la profession de jardiniers étaient
embrasés un peu par défaut oui je vous
rappelle nous en avions parlé lorsque
vous m'avez invité et dire quelques
temps déjà que ma famille lorsque je
suis rentré à versailles me surnommait
la bouse cela vous donne
faut prendre avec humour mais cela vous
donne effectivement l'idée de la
perception que l'on avait du métier de
jardinier le jardinier dans les années
1980 en général pas tous mais souvent
c'était un garçon vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de films en échec scolaire ou
en difficulté 6 actions ou qui souffrait
d'un handicap dont je suis très heureux
car je pense avoir un peu contribué à ce
jeune homme dont elle a été filmée que
j'espère je ne suis pas tout seul et
nabil d'autres et aujourd'hui le métier
qui est le mien représente la société
française telle qu'elle est il ya des
jeunes des moins jeunes des vieux il ya
des hommes il ya des femmes et les
personnes en souffrance des personnes
entendues cap et à des intelligents d un
petit peu moins aidé pas du tout il ya
des brouilles à des moches via la presse
société et c'est ce qui me plaît enfin
le métier de journée le plus noble
d'après voltaire est devenu une
profession normal voilà qu'on peut
embrasser par vocation ou en maison
l'ouvragé met justement
grâce à votre livre alors une fois ceci
dit est ce qu'une crise en ce moment du
métier gentillesse qu'on manque déjà
digne en france on en manque parce que
souvenez vous lors de la lors du premier
confinement les manifestations de colère
quant à propos de la fermeture des
squares et jardins parisiens les gens
réclamaient donc oui la la la la colle
la profession demande quantité de main
d'oeuvre c'est donc un métier qui
actuellement ne recrute pas comme il
devrait recruter enfin ne devrait pas
devoir écouter et donc c'est un métier
en devenir je suis con imaginez une
société sans jardin oui on ne peut même
pas être là là qu'on se voit donc le le
monde du jardin est en train d'évoluer
je suis persuadé que ceux qui se
destineront demain aux métiers de
l'horticulture et bien feront un très
bon choix rang de quoi contient leur
passion et travail est d'autant plus que
c'est un métier qui rend heureux c'est
un métier de liberté c'est un métier
vous n'avez pas besoin de lever la main
pour interpeller un contremaître parce
que vous avez besoin de vous isoler
quelques instants c'est un métier
également pied positif vous planter des
fleurs colorées l'évident quoi est-ce
qu'on a trop d'allergie en ville parce
que les citoyens sont devenus un petit
peu trop sensible ce sont un petit peu
trop côté protéger et peut-être aussi
que les jardiniers n'ont pas planter les
bonnes naissance a dit vous avez des
plantes qui développe davantage de
pollen que d'autres on pourrait
peut-être en tenir compte quand on
plante les végétaux on a trop voulu dans
un premier temps faire plaisir aux
citoyens en y plantant des végétaux
inadapté on a trafiqué la nature pour
prenons les hommes simples du ginkgo
biloba le gène beau produit des fruits
qu'ils payent a pas d'autre mot donc
pour éviter que le fruit ne tachent les
trottoirs et n'empêche on ne plante en
ville que des jeunes beaux mâles voilà
un exemple concret dont on a voulu
mettre des plantes qui obéissent aux
modes et nos communes nos villes ont été
prioritairement planté d'arbres qui
produisent ces fameux pollen qui peuvent
parfois
ja.b alors c'est l'une des explications
est venue on en a d'autres mais d'un
côté le citoyen devient un petit peu
délicat et d'un autre côté les
jardiniers à une époque on trop penser à
la beauté des yeux sans penser au
confort de l'usager c'est en train de
changer et sans voir plus loin que
l'esthétisme tout on est d'accord et
alors comment eux moi j'ai appris aussi
un truc aquatique le compost pour moi
mon métier un peu tout et n'importe quoi
dans un compost du monde c'était végétal
alors vous nous dites pas d'agrumes vous
avez le droit déjà d'attirer toutes les
baies vermine de de la région chez vous
si vous voulez y mettre plus que l'on
vous dit dans dans quelques revues
n'allant non mais soyons là comment
voulez vous avoir un compost bio avoir
un terreau bio si vous émettez par
exemple des agrumes qui ont été traitées
chimiquement sur la patience
mes produits et puis la difficulté la
longue la lenteur pour se dégrader
j'aime bien l'idée du compost qui
effectivement est utilisé plus d'années
à l'année d'après donc on peut mettre d
d d d d d angle mais encore été raisonné
et bien et uniquement si elles sont bio
oui oui parce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est le résultat et le produit d'ordre
dans le dos lors de ce retour dans
l'otan y avait un petit peu plus loin
que le bout de son nez bon alors très
bien et puis un dernier truc comment
attirer des régions c'est possible ou
pas bah déjà à produire la première
chose à faire c'est peut-être pas les
acides de les attirer mais d'éviter de
faire partie on y pense trop peu donc
quand on a élu son on le regarde alors
que faut-il faire ne pas toucher au tas
de branchages au fond du jardin sans les
y est pourquoi ne pas en créer un tas de
branchages pour faire là bas pour le
faire pour le faire venir aucun quand
vous avez constaté sa présence vous ne
touchez plus à rien et vous n'oubliez
jamais se fait un petit étang de mètres
au milieu une grosse pierre pour que
s'il venait à tomber dans l'eau ils
puissent se protéger voilà ses atouts
oui voilà alors à la baratte on merci on
pourrait dire encore plein de choses
mais le mieux c'est bien ce livre ce fut
une complètement passionnant et d'écouté
a très vite j'espère pour un nouvel
ouvrage très bientôt c'est vrai ça veut
dire quoi ça ça veut dire que je sorte
là dans les jours qui viennent un autre
livre pour les grands cette fois c'est
mon tour de france des bois et forêts
j'avais envie d'expliquer aux gens
pourquoi les bois s'appelle le bois de
fausses reposes pieds de table a connu
la ligue
pourquoi s'appelle-t-il bois de fausses
reposes la réponse est non et le bois de
saint qq fans et tous ses livres olala
j'ai hâte à merci à la foire des invités
mais
avec grande joie a très vite a prévu au
revoir à tous merci de nous avoir suivi
et à très bientôt pour un nouveau numéro
de villepin
[Musique]